comment est ce que c'est possible que ça
arrive qu'est-ce qu'on a tous comme
responsabilité collective pour que ça
arrive c'est ça dont on parle si vous
voulez les monstres ça n'existe pas
c'est notre société c'est nous c'est nos
amis c'est nos pères c'est c'est ça
qu'on doit regarder et ça veut pas dire
que qu'on doit comment dire je veux dire
on n'est pas là pour les éliminer on est
là pour les faire changer
[Musique]
j'espère que j'ai pas un statut qui va
qui va trop vite en fait j'espère que je
vais continuer à faire les films que que
je fais voilà qui sont peut-être plus
fragile plus fous
[Musique]
j'ai choqué par tout ce qu'il dit mais
choqué s'il fallait encore plus par le
fait qu'ils disent qui m'a découverte
parce qu'en fait il m'a surtout
détruites d'accord et qu'en fait si
christophe fozza eu l'emprise sur moi
c'est parce que moi le travail sur le
jeu le théâtre c'est quelque chose que
j'ai viscéralement dans le corps
[Musique]
la soutient et je pense qu'il faut
soutenir abel parce que d'abord elle est
la première personnalité vraiment du
cinéma affaires à faire bouger les
choses et c'est un monde qui à mon avis
comme les autres aussi doivent être
peuplée de prédateurs
[Musique]
je suis vraiment ému de voir la
reconnaissance de la profession et ont
symboliquement aussi parce que césar ça
sonne un peu comme oscar donc ça fait un
peu rêver je ne sais pas
[Musique]
c'est incroyable en fait rien il ya
quelque part quelque chose qui va pas en
fait c'est pas possible de venez le
césar qu'il ya catherine deneuve en lice
non enfin bon c'est très bien
[Musique]
le film a été écrit pour adel il a été
construit en pensant à eux aussi assez
possible voilà ouais il s'est hissé
fondée en sur ce qu'on sait d'elle est
tellement une femme pour n'en voit se
faire broyer phase soit dans les façon
dont on va récupérer leurs plaintes soit
dans la façon dont on va disséquer leur
vie et puis porter leur cul le regard
sur elle la photo cl alors comment elle
s'est habillée qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit qu'est-ce
qu'elle a bu mais arrêtons quoi je pense
qu'elle a tort de penser que la justice
ne peut pas répondre à ce type de
situation je pense au contraire
surtout avec ce qu'elle a dit qu'elle
devrait saisir la justice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pense que les problématiques qui sont
soulevées dans le film sont quand même
des problématiques qui font résonance
avec avec aujourd'hui l'amour entre deux
femmes l'avortement par exemple par
exemple louis et qui me semble des
problématiques on ne peut plus actuel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est difficile de jouer
aujourd'hui franchement on a une
pression de fou quoi pour réussir quand
on voit le taux de chômage être comme ça
le déterminisme social et tout ça c'est
un truc quand même donc ouais c'est
difficile d'être jeune aujourd'hui oui
carrément je suis solidaire de des gens
qui se révoltent quoi